today's medical sutures come in
different forms such as synthetic
monofilament threads natural collagen
fibers or braided synthetic threads
a technician sets a tension meter to
check the quality of the raw materials
the machine applies tension on the knot
to measure the force needed to break it
a worker test the materials absorption
process in a heated bath this simulates
the temperature and moisture of the
human body
a technician enters the products medical
specifications and prints out a batch of
labels the supervisor gathers all the
materials and brings them to the
material preparation department the
supplies are passed through an airlock
to maintain the department's positive
pressure environment
on the other side a technician opens the
airtight foil and removes the thread
spool she threads the spool in a
custom-made winding and cutting machine
the technician sets the mechanical
thread counter back to zero and starts
the winder it can line threads that are
up to 100 inches the counter tracks the
number of windings as the Machine
unspools the thread the machine stops
automatically once the winding is
complete
the technician applies medical grade
glue to stiffen the ends of the braided
threads before cutting them she places a
guy to hold the threads in place while
she cuts them along the glue line
sutures use needles of various shapes
and sizes the smallest ones being ten
millimeters in length
on the main production floor dozens of
workers attach needles to the threats
they make sure the attachment meets the
center's requirements
the operator inserts the glue hardened
end of the thread into the back of the
needle and crimps it tight with a
mechanical swaging machine
then she hooks the needle into a full
tester to check the strength of each
attachment finally workers wind the
assembled sutures into folded holding
cards tucking the needles in for
protection
sutures can be used for a variety of
procedures but each product has a very
precise application
you